uh murder ball was yeah murder ball was
dope man merbal british bulldog was my
favorite because that was just like
bashing in other kids that was just like
you just charge and tackle them i think
pretty much is what we did with british
bulldog
just beat the crap out of other kids
so into that man but
i doubt they do that today now it's
carry flags and um if you have a pronoun
and um you know go use the
inclusive bathroom that's like whatever
gender you want it to be and it's like
i'd like look
stuff like that's probably always been
around her for being honest but now it's
like they just want to shove it down
everybody's throat all the time you turn
on cable tv you know you watch a
commercial on a billboard or on tv or if
you're in an elevator or your dentist's
office or some [ __ ] like that i don't
have cable like i cancelled my cable
2012
it's been over a decade i've not had
cable i don't watch that [ __ ] the stupid
thing about cable that i don't
understand and why people still have it
is you're paying for them to serve
[ __ ] that's gonna brainwash you
you're actually paying them to brainwash
use the stupidest [ __ ] setup i've
ever seen and if you're still running
cable right now ask yourself this
question why the [ __ ] am i paying them
to brainwash me with this horseshit or
brainwash my kids or my wife or whoever
who happens to live in your house
because that's what you're basically
doing
they're polluting you with messages that
do not serve you at all okay
in that video that i talked about when i
kicked off at the start there was um
i think was a roomba vacuum commercial
that i inserted into that video from six
years ago and i was talking about how
essentially
uh advertisements and commercials
basically portray men as bumbling
[ __ ] idiots that are absolutely
incompetent and absolutely useless
and men are the s and sorry and women
are the saviors of the household they're
responsible they can get things done
they know how to get tidy so the so the
commercials are now
at that time six years ago when i
presented that are serving narratives
and lies and
um trying to brainwash people into
believing that guys are stupid and women
are superior and we should always defer
to them and just give her all your money
and let her go buy whatever she wants
including whatever the [ __ ] it is
they're trying to sell you in the
commercial
and that's how they've been rolling for
a while
they do that today and it's even worse
today right now they're now it's
whatever the new thing is that's that's
trending whether it's
get jabs support a flag or that flag or
a country war or whatever i mean hey
here's a new flash
do you think maybe both putin and
zielinski are [ __ ]
i don't know i'm just throwing it out
there why did it like why do you have to
support the new thing or trending thing
right like why can't we think for
ourselves it's like you know if you
don't update your [ __ ] facebook with
some circle flag around you
supporting whatever the new thing is
then people are like oh well he's not
conforming to the narrative he's not one
of the sheep yeah you're damn right
sitcoms i don't even watch anymore i
couldn't i couldn't watch uh
[ __ ] i mean you know you can go back to
the cosby show
right bill cosby was portrayed as a
[ __ ] all the women in the family were
the best and he was an idiot sort of
thing
uh fresh prince of bel-air right she ran
the household you know the big bad judge
the you know the bad boy you know he got
his ass licked every single time by his
wife
so again this is not a new phenomenon
it's been going on for decades now and
you wonder why you're dealing with a
generation of boss [ __ ] today
i was at the gym
doing my chest workout got the plates on
feeling good got a pump i'm listening to
this [ __ ] personal trainer talking to
this middle-aged woman
telling her that she's a bad boss [ __ ]
for
moving metal up and down you know sort
of thing like
this this this hashtag boss [ __ ] gets
thrown at everything nowadays um i had
an interview on a woman's podcast a
couple weeks ago you'll find some of the
clips on my clips channel now uh they
live there
and um i mean you know she was pleasant
she was inviting she had read my book
she said her boyfriend you know read my
book
um and there's a clip on there somewhere
where we're talking about um
you know culture polluting the minds of
you know people like we are today sort
of thing and she's sitting there wearing
a bad [ __ ] t-shirt with tats and was a
single mom as well
um and you know we're talking about red
flags right but
you come to these realizations and you
see the code in the matrix when you read
my book when you watch my content when
you see enough of my podcast when i do
these one-on-one consults like people
get to it eventually right but then
they've like left this trail of bad
decisions along the way and they run a
bass
boss [ __ ] business and they've got
sleeve tats sort of thing right
like high notch counts men aren't
generally interested in women that have
a high
like number of visible tattoos right
like
tattooing is a
tattooing women is a more modern
phenomenon okay
men it's been around for a long time in
some cultures in some societies it's
existed in part of the female population
but it's primarily
masculine dominance right
it's it's just weird man like all of
these things that happen i think i think
that the most dangerous one for guys
today
are the covert feminists okay um
that uh chick that that pretty girl that
dealt with andrew in that clip that i
mentioned earlier is a classic example
of a covert feminist
um i'm pretty i i have i have the flash
and the pizzazz so
in today's modern world it's not just
like the like the psychos that you see
trending on um twitter or on social
media that are yelling um you know like
here i got another one here in my
timeline
this one
you've probably seen this one too
like they don't just look like this
anymore right
come on play back
right to the start like they don't just
look like this anymore
this is you know this is what you've
been you know used to you know this is
what you've been told just stay away
from that but that's not enough anymore
right
most of these women that you're going to
deal with today
um as you come across them on dating
apps or a cold approach or you know
social events or whatever you happen to
be doing
um you're going to run into a good
number of them
that are that that have polluted values
that have uh toxic feminist values that
are instilled in them
men and women are equal but take me out
to dinner
men and women are equal
but uh you know go out make the money
and take care of me and i'll stay home
and raise the kids right
it's like
you know and then you ask them a
question like hey do you think you could
beat me up you know are men and women
really equals like no you can't like
even if i had one of my arms tied behind
my back even a chick that competes at my
dojo probably couldn't beat me up right
it's like men and women are different
and
why do we stray away from that
why because society culture i'll tell
you what it is it's a psyop you know at
the end of the day
they don't want you strong and
independent and thinking for yourself
they want you plugged into narratives
they want you plugged into lies i mean
there's a reason why my book was called
the unplugged alpha because you're
unplugging from [ __ ] that doesn't
serve you
when you go far enough down the rabbit
hole and you start to see all this code
in the matrix covert feminists pop like
that like as soon as i
hear one of these chicks talking for a
few minutes oh she's a covert feminist
automatically right and then you've got
ones that
look more feminist but are trying to
return to their more natural roots like
that leandra
chick that did that podcast on my clips
channel you again you'll see the clips
over there
um
but yeah i mean
you know they lie to women about having
a family it's go get a degree go and buy
your own house get your own car you
don't need no man and then they end up
being like 39 or 40 and then they're
just like well you know i should have
done this in my 20s
um
that's when you get those chicks on the
dating apps that are that are uh
that have baby rabies and they're like
if you don't want to talk about kids on
the first date then i don't even want to
go out with you say
why did you even waste your time dude
why would you why like why not just like
start googling i wonder what would
happen if i put my penis in a pencil
sharpener right like it's it's like the
same thing
you're inviting chaos man
but that's where we get to right
society celebrates single mothers
big time
big
time you're so strong and independent
i do the job of a mother and a father
you know you see that on father's day
all the time right
what's to celebrate
the kid doesn't have a father or you've
removed him from the household or you
scared him off or
any number of things could have you know
could have happened guy was a degenerate
loser right
this is what happens when you don't
allow fathers or men
to play a role
in girls and who they date and when they
date and you know arranging marriages
and stuff like that like there's like
there's a strong argument for a strong
culture when you do stuff like that i'm
not saying that that's where things need
to go
i don't think things were really
there to that to that degree in north
american culture
north america is so interesting man
yeah
um
they teach men to never stand up to
women that's another note that i jotted
down over here
it's like
you're not allowed to have an opinion
you're not allowed to offer a view it's
like
how many guys i've heard say happy wife
happy life it's just it just drives me
and say every time i [ __ ] hear it
somewhere social gathering some event
you know hearing an in-law or like a
relative of in-law you know regurgitate
that that lyric happy wife happy life
and you like you know dude you're not
banging like i can tell
i know what the face of a guy looks like
that's banging a lot versus the guy
that's not and it's like
if you're taught never to stand up to
women women aren't going to respect you
one and two you're never really going to
optimize yourself to have the best
experience and you're sure as [ __ ] not
going to raise useful kids you're going
to raise [ __ ]
right
yeah
man caves that's another one i've talked
about a few times i want to talk about
man caves again
you see these guys that are all proud to
have their [ __ ] tvs and their couches
and some beer fridge in their garage and
they're like oh yeah i'm watching a game
in my man cave i'm the [ __ ] dude yeah
[Applause]
while the wife [ __ ] runs the entire
house and he pays for it all
you're not the dude if you're rolling in
a man cave
my house is my man cave
that's an eight thousand dollar
restoration hardware couch okay
chicks would not let you spend that kind
of money on a couch that looks like that
oh that's not a good-looking couch i
don't give a [ __ ] it's mine
my house is my man cave
all right
let me get the uh call in link
uh
where's my invite let's chop it up with
some people i got a couple other notes
here but i just wanted to get the call
and link out there
before we do this
all right
call in and ask a question
all right um
all right so there's a stream yard link
and i pretty sure if that goes to my
youtube i can pin it
oh yes the option is available still
thank you so let's pin at the top of the
youtube so if you guys are watching
somewhere else
um on the internets make sure you're
over on youtube and stream yard link is
there
every couple of days i get an email or
dm from somebody that's like hey i want
to call in your show how do i do it it's
like dude watch the show live i always
give you the instructions live
hey guys i really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unplugged alpha dot com forward slash
shop when you click through you'll be
able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model where regular shipments will be
sent over to you on a regular basis and
that gives you a little bit of a
discount and your supplement facts are
always broken down over here thanks for
watching i hope you guys have an awesome
day and again check out that link it's
pinned in the top comment below in this
video peace out
you